buenos días aquí steve gorman
y hoy voy a hablar sobre la importancia
de la escucha en el aprendizaje de
idiomas
si te gustan mis vídeos
inscríbete
haz clic en la campana para recibir
noticias
y si me sigues en el podcast en podcast
puedes dejar un comentario
agradeciera mucho bueno la escucha la
escucha es la actividad en mi caso en el
aprendizaje de idiomas es la cosa que
hago lo más frecuentemente porque es la
actividad más fácil es más es muy fácil
yo me levanto a la mañana puedo escuchar
preparando el desayuno puedes puedo
escuchar en el coche puedes escuchar
y durante el día hay tantas ocasiones
aquí 10 minutos 30 minutos que puedo
escuchar y escuchando inevitablemente
hay cosas que yo no he comprendido
entendido pues ese este es una
estimulación ahora quiero leer para
saber y entender mejor las secciones de
cosa que he entendido que no he
entendido la cosa que he escuchado que
no he entendido no cumpliendo entonces
es una me empuja le empuja a leer y
escuchando y leyendo
voy a aprender porque como digo siempre
el input es esta cosa de escuchar el jr
hacer que el idioma entra en su que
entre en su cabeza en su cerebro esa es
la mejor manera para aprender no se
aprende hablando hablando es cuando se
puede
actividad
todas las cosas que ya has has aprendido
y la escucha tiene la gran ventaja que
se puede hacer
cuando quieres
es importante darse cuenta que no
necesitas enfocarse siempre no hay gente
que creen que debe deben escuchar que
atenten atentamente para no
faltar cosas no yo escucho y de vez en
cuando
mi mente está un poco distraído no voy a
enfocarme voy pensar otras cosas para
entonces volver a escuchar y si yo
escucho como yo no sé 20 minutos si el
pierre periodo de concentración es de
50% o 60% ya es mucho ya es mucho es que
el idioma está entrando en tu cabeza
aún el tiempo que no estás
concentrándose es todavía está entero
entrando en su cabeza y los períodos que
estás escuchando con concentración tanto
mejor y yo tengo una en estrategia que
durante el primer periodo del
aprendizaje de un idioma cualquiera pues
voy a escuchar muchas veces la misma
cosa muchas veces sobre todo las mini
historias donde hay mucha repetición de
vocabulario y escuchando una u otra vez
tendría tanta repetición que
los neuron es bueno conectar en mi
cerebro
este es durante la
según según el idioma los tres meses
seis meses voy a escuchar la misma cosa
una u otra vez este no quiere decir en
un rato
en seguida no voy escuchar la primera
historia la segunda la tercera la cuarta
y después la primera la segunda y
finalmente al cabo de todo yo porque
tenemos las estadísticas en link yo voy
a ver que finalmente he escuchado una
historia 30 veces 30 veces bueno no es
todo el mundo que tiene la paciencia de
hacerlo pero puedo asegurarles de que
hacer esto en el fase no al inicio ayuda
mucho para para que el cerebro sea que
se acostumbre al nuevo idioma tiene que
forzar en el cde por crear un
un centro de control no por el nuevo
idioma pero después de este rato pues
voy a escuchar menos frecuenta
frecuentemente la misma el mismo
contenido porque ahora bueno
es este
está
aburrido de escuchar siempre la misma
cosa entonces el cerebro qué
necesita repetición para aprender pero
también necesita novedad necesita cosas
interesantes y dispuesto de los primeros
34 meses voy a buscar cosas interesantes
para escuchar porque el camino es muy
largo necesita mucho tiempo para
aprender entonces tienes que buscar
contenidos interesantes
divirtiéndose
de manera que el aprendizaje no es para
aprender
el idioma para aprender sobre cosas que
son interesantes para ti entonces la
estrategia de escuchar se cambia se
cambia de una estrategia
de repetición mucha repetición
hacia una estrategia de descubrir
descubrir no sólo el idioma pero la
cultura el país y todo lo que tiene
relaciones con el idioma que estás
estudiando entonces él es él y la
escucha te prepara para hablar porque si
tú quieres tener una conversación con
alguien en el idioma que estás
aprendiendo sobre todo un nativo en
activo tiene un tiene mucho mucho más
vocabulario que ti entonces tienes que
tener un gran vocabulario pasivo tienes
que entender entonces la comprensión es
muy importante si tú no tienes este
nivel de comprensión es muy difícil
tener una conversación de adulto con
alguien
entonces
aunque la meta es de poder hablar bien
con
cualquier persona
la manera de llegar a esta capacidad es
a través de la escucha la comprensión la
comprensión oral si tienes este
comprensión oral puedes mantener
conversaciones inteligentes
todo el nivel nivel en el idioma va
a mejorarse entonces finalmente la
escucha es la actividad más fácil pero
la actividad clave para
alcanzará un nivel nivel de fluidez en
cualquier idioma bueno
hasta luego muchas gracias de la escucha
de la escucha